[Musique]
j'ai toujours été très consciente de mon
identité
automatique
michel ou bones a ruiné tous les
bénéfices c'est dans cette langue qui
s'est présentée à la chambre des
communes
coincoin niveau bac new delhi with him
is hell is the band swing nadia oui
odanak
[Musique]
août donne accès le village d'origine
des eaux-bonnes samhain sur le bord de
la rivière saint-françois au québec
l'arrière grand père de la juge avait
quitté sa famille pour aller travailler
dans une mine près de saugues brute mon
père m'a raconté que lorsqu'il était
enfin les autres il ya souvent de lui de
sa famille puis il l'appelait le petit
sauvage de la rue sony brille la juge se
définit aussi comme franco ontarienne je
me suis fait dire que comme sites
francophones du nord de l'ontario la
carrière d'avocate n'était peut-être
vraiment pas pour moi je me suis dit ah
oui regardez moi ben ali
[Musique]
qui
lie
les deux accusés partagent une passion
les voitures anciennes ils ont un combat
en commun la sauvegarde de leur culture
d'amiens ne les a rencontrés l'avocate
dans les cours de langue abénaquise qui
suivent ensemble quake wars
pétard ou la location nous jeter à l'eau
quand morgan co suprême du canada ils ne
sont plus qu'une douzaine à la parler
pour quelqu'un qui est juste quelques
années qu'il qu'il la prend et très bon
très très bonne oui les foyers gérés nul
mais c'est alain très belle
prononciation puis ce qui nous distingue
c'est cette culture là si on a des
choses en particulier qui nous distingue
des ombres gardons le bigard dont le
farouchement se battre farouchement
michel eaubonne samhain le fait ou si
quand elle porte la toge pour que les
autochtones vulnérables soient mieux
compris par les tribunaux la santé
mentale faisaient l'objet de nombreux
préjugés
j'ai constaté une évolution au fil des
ans et une diminution de cette
stigmatisation
mais il y a encore beaucoup beaucoup de
chemin à faire l'avocate est devenue une
experte du droits en santé mentale et
des principes de la règle a dû ce
jugement de la cour suprême impose aux
juges de considérer dans leur décision
les circonstances uniques des premières
nations leurs blessures leurs passés de
peuples colonisés
[Musique]
ce professeur a dirigé la thèse de
doctorat de la jugent bonne samhain son
moment on est qu'elle serait que dans le
soir je le disais que les canadiens il
estime que son ancienne étudiante
apportera une expertise unique à la cour
suprême michel avec une expertise
entretien jeudi pottok tonnes et en
expériences vécues et de recherche sous
la souris présentation du docteur
différents systèmes justice ça change la
conversation
d'avoir quelqu'un qui
peuvent espérer devenir quelque chose
comme ça donne qu'est ce que c'est
possible que c'est faisable